MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: AS WE SAID AT THE
OPEN, THERE’S BREAKING NEWS FROM
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
WE’RE NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT SOME
OF IT MEANS.
BUT IT IS COMING AT US RIGHT
NOW.
JAMES COMEY TESTIFIED ON CAPITOL
HILL TODAY.
HE DROPPED HIS INITIAL PLANS TO
MANY LEGAL CHAPLAINS TO THE
SUBPOENA HE RECEIVED.
WHAT DID WE LEARN FROM COMEY ON
THE HILL?
TOM WAS WATCHING CAREFULLY.
HE’S PRESIDENT OF JUDICIAL
WATCH.
HE’S HERE TO TELL US ABOUT THAT
AND TO ASSESS THE MEMOS.
FIRST TO COMEY.
TOM, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DID WE LEARN?
>> WE LEARNED THAT COMEY IS NOT
WORRIED ABOUT BEING PROSECUTED
BECAUSE HE DIDN’T TAKE THE FIFTH
AND WE LEARNED THAT THE FBI AND
JUST IT’S THE DEPARTMENT ARE
STILL HAMPERING THE
INVESTIGATION BY ORDERING HIM
NOT TO ANSWER KEY QUESTIONS
ACCORDING TO REPUBLICANS THAT
COMPLAINED ABOUT THE WAY IT
PROCEEDED.
>> Tucker: CAN I ASK A QUESTION?
AM I OVERSTATING THIS?
I WANT TO BE FAIR.
IT SEEMED TO ME LIKE HE
COMMITTED PERJURY BECAUSE HE
SAID HE NEVER PARTICIPATED IN
LEAKING WHILE FBI DIRECTOR AND
ANDY McCABE SAID HE HAD.
DID ANYBODY ASK HIM ABOUT THAT?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
DEPENDS ON THE MEANING OF LEAK.
>> Tucker: I GUESS IT DOES.
>> HE TOOK THE FIB MEMOS, THE
FILES OF TRUMP ARE UP AND LEAKED
THEM WITH A SPECIFIC PERSON OF
GETTING A SPECIAL COUNSEL
APPOINTED.
HE OUGHT TO BE UNDER CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION FOR TAKING THE
RECORDS AND LEAKING THEM AND
ALSO UNDER INVESTIGATION ABOUT
TAKING CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
IF YOU’RE UNDER CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND SOMEONE ASKS YOU
QUESTION ABOUT IT AND THE
OFFICIAL CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE THIS,
YOU TAKE THE FIFTH.
>> Tucker: GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS
WAS IN PRISON UNTIL A MINUTE
AGO.
ARE YOU GETTING THE IMPRESSION
THAT THE TRULY POWERFUL DON’T
FACE LEGAL CONSEQUENCES?
IT’S ALWAYS THE LITTLE GUY.
JEROME CORSI, SOME 72-YEAR-OLD
WRITER THAT GETS THREATENED.
BY JAMES COMEY GETS TO DO
WHATEVER HE WANTS?
>> IT’S NOT NECESSARILY POWERFUL
BUT A PARTISAN PROCESS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS POWERFUL BUT
HE’S BEING ATTACKED AND ABUSED.
>> Tucker: GOOD POINT.
>> IF YOU’RE CONNECTED TO THE
DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT, YOU’RE
PROTECTED.
MR. COMEY IS MUELLER’S WITNESS.
HE APPOINTED MUELLER.
HE WORKED WITH MUELLER.
HIS FRIENDS WITH MUELLER.
NOW WE’RE SEEING WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU’RE ONE OF THE FRIENDS OF
MUELLER.
YOU GET PROTECTED BY THIS
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THIS FBI.
IF YOU’RE NOT A FRIEND OF
MUELLER, YOU’LL BE USED AND
ABUSED IN THE CASE OF COHEN WHO
WAS USED TO GO AFTER TRUMP IN A
DISHONEST WAYS IN MY VIEW BY
THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL AND BEING
ABUSED AND THROWN UNDER THE BUS.
OH, YEAH, WE USED HIS TESTIMONY.
WE’RE ABLE TO INSERT THE WORD
"RUSSIA" 50 MILLION TIMES AS A
RESULT OF THESE PLEA DEALS THAT
DIDN’T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
DIDN’T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA COLLUSION BUT WE’RE GOING
RUSSIA COLLUSION BUT WE’RE GOINGTO ASK THE COURT TO ALLOW HIM TO
TO ASK THE COURT TO ALLOW HIM TO
GO TO JAIL FOR 3 1/2 YEARS.
>> Tucker: MAKING THIS CYNICAL.
I WISH IT WASN’T.
I LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
THERE’S A RULE TODAY IN
HILLARY’S E-MAILS.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> A BIG RULING BY JUDGE ROYCE
LAMBERT THAT OPENED DISCOVERY IN
THE CLINTON E-MAIL ISSUE.
HE’S ANGRY ABOUT WHAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI
DID.
HE FEARS HE WAS HOODWINKED AND
KEPT THE E-MAILS AWAY US FROM.
HE’S CONCERNED THAT HILLARY
CLINTON CREATED THIS E-MAIL
SYSTEM TO AVOID JUSTICE AND HE
WENT AFTER THIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR COMING IN COURT
AND ENGAGING IN CHICANERY TO
MAKE EXCUSES FOR AND EXPLAIN
AWAY THE MISCONDUCT THAT SAW THE
E-MAILS HIDDEN AND THE E-MAIL
SYSTEM USED TO AVOID COURT
SCRUTINY, CONGRESSIONAL SCRUTINY
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IN FACT, HE ASKED, WAS BENGHAZI
ONE OF THE REASONS THEY DIDN’T
WANT US TO KNOW ABOUT THE
E-MAILS?
THIS DISCOVERY IS SIGNIFICANT.
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
>> CONGRESS IS OUT TO LUNCH ON
THIS.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
THE COURT WANTS MORE ANSWERS.
>> Tucker: WHAT HAPPENED TO THE